-This is
a zombie-apocalypse movie
with a fantastic cast.
-Yeah.
-Adam Driver, Bill Murray,
Tilda Swinton,
Chloe Sevigny, yourself.
Jim Jarmusch directed it.
This is not a man who is known
for his zombie films.
-No, he's not.
-Yeah.
-By the way, that clip
was just from footage
of my house upstate.
-Yeah.
-I don't know how you got that
That's me every morning.
-I'm so sorry.
They told us that was from
the movie, but that's just -
that's actual documentary-film
footage of you...
-Yes.
-...and your farm.
Well, I feel terrible.
We have violated your privacy,
and I apologize.
-That's okay.
But you -- you do play a farmer.
-Yes.
-And you sort of --
I guess, as that clip tells us
you might realize
something's wrong
'cause your animals go missing
-Something's going on
in the town.
-Yeah.
-It's very troubling, yes.
-There's a lot of prosthetic
as you would expect
from a zombie film.
Did you enjoy
that part of the job?
-No.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, I mean, everybody's nice,
you know,
but it takes a long time..
-Yeah.
-...to put the makeup on.
And then you look like a zombie,
and nobody wants
to talk to you, really.
-Did you feel same way
about your cast members
who were the zombies?
-Yeah.
Well, Chloe Sevigny
is in the film,
and I hadn't seen her
in a long time,
and we were catching up.
But -- And I --
You know,
having a serious conversation,
but I couldn't
look her in the eye
'cause, literally, her eye was
like, falling out of her head.
[ Laughter ]
Had to stop talking.
-Yeah, it's very hard to -
Somebody you haven't seen
in 10 years and you have to say,
"You look great..."
-Yeah, right.
-"...you haven't aged a day,
with like a dead, lolling eye.
Bill Murray's
one of your co-stars.
Have you work together before?
-Never.
-But you did --
You auditioned for him.
-I did.
You know, he co-directed a film,
"Quick Change."
-Yeah, fantastic film.
-And I auditioned for it.
I didn't get the part.
But he told me
when I came in that --
He said,
"We looked at your picture
and you sort of
look like a psycho."
[ Laughter ]
"And you come in here, and you
really do look like a psycho."
[ Laughter ]
"It's just most people
don't look like their pictures."
-That's so nice.
-I said, "Thank you."
-But this is true.
In your early days,
you had two head shots.
-I did, yeah.
-And so you would decide,
based on the role, whether
to send out the psycho one
-Well, I didn't think
I looked like a psycho.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Well, here --
This is obviously your --
-Yeah. That's like, you know
like...the boy next door.
-Boy next door.
-You know.
-And this is the guy who maybe
has some trouble
with the boy next door.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that's --
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, that's the same gu
but very different parts.
-But here's the weird thing.
That's how I really
preferred to look.
Like, I --
It was the '80s, you know,
so, like, a lot of hair gel.
-A lot of hair gel.
-That's how I walked around.
Yeah.
-You found your first --
This is your first --
what would you say? --
your acting résumé?
Is that...?
-Yeah.
-And not a lot going on here
-No, it's very slight.
-Yeah.
-Is it true that you --
'Cause you did
some stand-up comedy.
-I did.
-But in your early days,
you actually thought
there was a chance --
Ventriloquism
was a thing you took.
-You know, when I was a kid,
you know,
I wanted to be in show business.
-Yeah.
-You know, I didn't necessaril
know, like, how to be an actor
but I figured,
you gotta know a lot of stuff.
So I learned how to juggle
I learned
how to ride a unicycle.
[ Light laughter ]
And then, I --
for a little while,
I thought, "Ventriloquism --
that's my ticket."
-And then, did you realize
that it was the '80s
and none of those skills
actually mattered anymore?
[ Laughter ]
-I was so disappointed.
-Yeah.
-Years of training.
-But then, the good news was
you know, you thought,
oh, you wasted all that time
learning how to do that stuff,
and in the end, they were like
"You know what's good, though?
You look a little bit
like a psycho."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-"We can use that."
So, you were doing stand-up,
and at the same
that you were doing stand-up
and you were acting,
you were also a fireman.
-I was.
-And not like
a volunteer fireman.
You were an actual fireman
-Yeah, at Engine 55
in Manhattan, and I did that -
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
I kind of kept it under wraps.
I mean, I had done
a little bit of stand-up,
and then I got called
for the job,
so I stopped doing stand-up,
and I just so --
And I was, like, the quietes
guy in the firehouse
'cause you didn't want
to give these guys
any ammunition
to make fun of you.
-Sure.
-Yeah.
So, it was like --
So you would never say, like
with everybody, "Did anybody
else here ride a unicycle?
You wouldn't -- yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And there was only one other --
there was another firefighte
that was an actor who worked
in another firehouse.
His name was Dean Tulipane
and -- and they made fun of him.
Like -- Like, night and day.
You know?
And so I definitely wasn't
gonna tell anybody that I --
And then, I met him.
And because I lived
in the East Village,
he knew something was up.
He said, "What are you --
You must be something.
A musician?
Are you an actor?"
And I admitted
that I was an actor,
or that I wanted to be an actor.
And then, so the cat
was out of the bag.
-And then they found out.
-And they tortured me.
-And they tortured you.
[ Light laughter ]
But you met -- Is it true
you met Jim Jarmusch,
the director of this film,
as a stand-up?
-Well, yes.
I was doing --
Well, not stand-up.
I had a partner, Mark Boone Jr.,
and we used to write --
-Who's a great actor.
-He's a wonderful actor.
And we used to write and perform
our own material.
And we used to do this show.
There was a comedian
called Rockets Redglare.
-Okay.
-Did you ever know him?
-No. Rockets -- His name
was Rockets Redglare?
-Rockets Redglare.
-Okay.
-And he used to do --
-Got to go into comedy
with a name like that.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
-And he had a show called
"Rockets Redglare's
Taxi's Cabaret."
And Boone and I
would perform in that,
and Jim used to see us in that
and that's how he cast me
in one of the early films,
"Mystery Train."
-Yeah.
-And -- And then,
right after "Mystery Train,"
the day we wrapped --
the next day,
we filmed a little short
that he used for
"Coffee and Cigarettes"
years later.
But I hadn't worked with him
in 30 years.
-That's fantastic.
-Yeah.
-It's a great film.
It's great to see you guys
collaborate again.
It's always such a pleasur
to have you here and see you
-Thank you, so much.